[Musique]
tu dois adopté la mentalité du flic de
base irlandais le monde est un véritable
enfer ses habitants sont des crétins
paresseux les minorités sont dangereuses
le sexe c'est mal mais intéressant et
demande doit ce qui fait peur à ma
grand-mère ou ce qui met les nerfs à mon
grand père il soutiendra un sujet pour
faire ça c'est tellement évident les
femmes sont partout même au tennis et au
golf rappelle ce lundi matin des
femelles
il va falloir sur l'islam le
comportement hors caméra était bien pire
tu es un petit mec il faut que tu
apprennes à vivre avec les hommes tu es
sexy mais était pénible regarder j'en ai
toute une liste vous croyez que d'autres
femmes vous suivront peut-être avez-vous
entendu parler d'un différend opposant
aux candidats à la présidence donald
trump du champ qui empêche les yeux du
sang qui sortait de partout
[ __ ] est ce qu'il est en train de dire
que j'étais énervé à cause de mes règles
c'est moi le centre de l'histoire non je
vais faire la une république n'arrête
pas de regarder parce qu'il est un
conflit ils s'arrêtent de regarder quand
il n'y en a aucun je veux vous
convaincre que ceci fait pour être à
l'antenne monsieur je pourrais être un
atout phénoménal ce vote russie je
pourrais faire en sorte que vous devenez
un élément phare de notre groupe et je
dois être sûr que vous êtes joyal j'ai
besoin de vous trouviez un moyen de me
le prouver mon père
k
[Musique]
tu sais pourquoi rogers verrouille
toujours la porte de son bureau
il faut que quelqu'un parle il faut que
quelqu'un se révoltent john carson à la
présentatrice de la chaîne aujourd'hui
qu'elle va détruire machette tout le
monde mal tee shirt pour soutenir what
they made it was i c'est la fin d'une
époque
tu comprends bien que je dois rester en
dehors de ça et toi tu as compris que le
pays tout entier ne parle que des règles
[Musique]
ma chérie les maîtres mots ici sans
sécurité vérité
prête à rentrer en guerre ouf
[Musique]